what do you get when you cross a
mentally ill owner in a society that
I've already done that bed John oh okay
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy we've done that wonderful
so I used to think my life was a tragedy
that can you introduce me as Joker dawn
oh I have our negative thoughts did you
come home just thinking of a joke do you
want to tell me you wouldn't get it
alright people well we let you guys vote
at our community page from the top three
well we could gather is the most
requested ones for the next trailers
revisited Joker easily took the vote but
the next two are second in third place
to keep a lookout for those videos this
is I think a day after the one year
anniversary of the Joker trailer debut
trailers revisited we go back and look
at the first trailer again to see how
accurately portrayed was the movie my
memory serves me correctly it's pretty
accurate accurate but a fun thing to
also do is also look at the initial
expectations that formed and then go in
don't get it watch it okay does it help
yeah someone to talk to
[Music]
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
[Music]
she told me I had a purpose to be
laughter enjoy to the world
[Music]
symbolism so many Easter eggs in that
one shot alone or is it getting crazier
out there
no your father was a good smile even
though it's breaking time when there are
in the sky
[Music]
as he fell
[Music]
Gotha has lost his way
what kind of coward reduced to think
that cold-blooded someone who hides
behind a mask
[Music]
funny looking back at this thinking
about how I thought these sequences
would play out yeah it's kind of
[Music]
it's a comedy I remember hearing that
line of the movie going oh man he's
saying that right before he kills his
mother which was like a surprising thing
to discover and an alternate take yeah
just
and also the last thing I was expecting
was that song when he walks down the
hallway in the actual movie yeah has
this fits so perfectly that I just
always associated that moment whoever
this trailer that when we got to here in
the actual movie where he's walking down
the hall goes on the stairs and it's
Gary Glitter instead yeah actually it
took me a while to readjust it cuz I'm
about you guys but I constantly watch
this trailer on my own time before the
movie came out I was kind of addicted to
it then watching that scene having a bit
of a difficulty readjusting my brain to
this I'm so used to the smile so I'm
going over it in the crescendo moment I
don't fifty Native other trailers
revisited but it'll be a little bit of a
different one because this one I feel
like will really be paced off of how I
really thought these sequences would
actually play out when watching the
movie because tonally it's pretty
accurate it's pretty spot-on
yeah it really captures the feeling I
mean for trailers which are often known
to be heavy on spoilers or miss
marketing the kind of film it is I think
this trailer really really gets it too
high and so did the second trailer
actually and the second trailer felt a
little bit more like just an expansion
of the first one obviously you're not
gonna get all the plot details in a
trailer so I love that they let a lot of
it lead with the visuals the mood and
the tone when really there's all these
different plot details that come out in
the film are not really alluded to and
here yeah you get the relationship with
the mom which I thought might be when
watching the film I thought was probably
gonna be a really endearing quality and
that she would probably have a tragedy
befall her and then he lose it and I
think a lot of people thought that that
he would like lose his mind because he
just lost his mother to some tragic
event which she does die in a tragic way
but to take this lie which obviously is
hinting at him morphing into from Arthur
Fleck and a joker
[Music]
but I don't think anyone thought he's
probably saying that when he's putting a
pillow over his mom's face right yeah
yeah seriously and that's part of the
fun I think of this particular set of
trailers just this one alone for now you
do get so many switcheroos I think feel
like with this movie especially because
there are so many things that when
isolated and so many lines of dialogue
too that when isolated just don't clue
you in Jeff the context I think they are
getting more conscientious as we push
forward in marketing with choosing those
moments and isolating those moments
because especially this film has a lot
of direct quotables that people have
latched on to and and again kind of like
we were touching on in the last trailers
revisited is some of the most iconic
moments here are alternate takes
anything my life was a tragedy so you
learned that delivery but it's not
really how it goes in the movie I think
what's funny is that this was like one
of the first trailers where we really
went on a hardcore trailer breakdown of
it then I watched some other people's
trailer breakdowns and we I think a lot
of us were really similar in how we
thought things might play out because
this trailer makes it look like he's
kind of leading a normal life and he's
like a mental health patient checking in
Arkham a lot the way they they cut it
together makes it look as if he has the
sign he gets it jacked from him like by
Act two I don't think a lot of us were
expecting that to be the opening Romeo
especially with a smile because the way
this trailer does it makes it seem like
that's closer to his breaking point yes
full Joker yeah whereas this movie
starts off just with that like brilliant
opening scene and so the trailer kind of
makes it look like he's gonna get hit by
the sign and then he's going to at some
point get on the subway and it's all
gonna happen in the same day yeah I
think a lot of us did predict that he
probably killed those people on the
subway and that's what they were talking
about what the gun stuff but then you
know there's also other elements that
are now really expanded upon in this
trailer that are heavily in the movie
but like a twist plot point though is he
related to the weight and you know like
that's a big moment you see the trailer
footage really why is he punching arth
reflect but no one was thinking that
might be the case yeah and I think a lot
of us also thought when he visits Bruce
Wayne oh that might be post Joker like
post after he's already evolved yeah
yeah yeah well and also to it
think some of the riot and civil unrest
sequences hit in a different way in the
actual film when I watched the trailers
back then I remembered thinking that he
gave rise to all of these riots and
people but I thought that he was more
embracing it earlier on especially the
way they sliced together the footage of
when he's looking at stuff I don't
remember if I thought it was purposeful
or accidental but it did come across
like he was embracing the rise but then
when you watch the movie he seems to
kind of resist it yeah yeah it seems
like there's this happening so
accidentally even though he was a big
start of it yeah it seemed like it's so
its own thing happening that's building
up as that's growing so is Joker growing
and then by the end then he truly
embraces that symbolism that icon that
he has become in these people's eyes the
trailer kind of makes it look like he's
doing that and that he's like kind of a
leader of the revolt in some way and I
think on top at that point this trailer
does at least to me you know initially
hint at the idea that he's going to
become the confident Joker who has that
you know always laughing always a beat
kind of thing whereas never in this
movie does he reached a point where he
is just consistently the traditional
Joker whereas in this trailer there were
flashes of moments where I'm like oh
maybe he's gonna become the traditional
Joker right and maybe this stuff on the
talk show is gonna play out entirely
differently because yeah you see the
movie then you realize like the Joker is
still being formulated even as he goes
on to Murray show you know well I think
the Murray Show point is probably the
biggest thing that I loved about
coinciding the storytelling of the
actual film with the trailer because
both trailers treat it as a build-up to
the actual interview and yet don't see
any glimpses of the you see glimpses of
pretty much everything else and you see
glimpses into before the interview and
he's in the green room you'll see that
but you don't actually see any footage
of the interview itself so I remember
being in the theater and like oh here's
here's the moment I think the trailers
have fun with you that like oh it's
building to this talk show interview
that's where this movie is headed I
think it like kind of subconsciously
programs the audience into remember
that like seeing this footage but also
going I actually don't know what goes on
in that interviews even though when I
was watching the movie I was like he's
probably gonna kill him it's kind of
like a to feeling it's what was a
surprise in this sense of like intensity
another was I'm not really shocked that
he did it yeah if that makes sense some
of the biggest quotes are coming from
that interview yeah the biggest I think
it's so grand that we were already
quoting this movie and making fun of it
and stop having so much fun with this
not make fun of it in a bad way but in
the way I was this was loved already and
then the scene that they reserved as the
ultimate finale moment cuz you you'll
even see the ambulance crash moment in
the trailer which is post Murray
interview but I love how both the
trailers don't show you any of that
footage really letting you feel a sense
of anticipation and build-up to that
interview I don't hope I feel like I saw
the word interview countless times ya
know I think this is a really well done
trailer in the sense that it really
represents the movie and the movies tone
it really feels like the movie but it
also leaves a lot of contextual
surprises and holes from footage across
the film but does a really nice job of
keeping the context pretty vague so yeah
this is a very successful trailer all
right guys Joker trailers revisited
complete head thank you guys for voting
on this one I didn't even realize that
it's the one-year anniversary of me and
we're a day late we're shooting this on
the day of or a day like a lot of so
need somebody technical today people
look out for the other two that have
been voted on and we want to do this
like weekly it's been a fun segment to
bring back how do you feel revisiting
this trailer any special thoughts that
come to mind did the movie live up to
your expectations subscribe to the reel
rejects click that notification bell to
keep a look at on our community page
because we are engaging there a lot more
than ever before
much love